hello and welcome to a brief clip from
this week's gamespot of Thrones if you'd
like to watch the full video head over
to youtube.com slash gamespot so the
show's writers are dropping really
clumsy heavy-handed hints that the
tallies are going to have some kind of
big resurgence and have a big part to
play in the latter half of this season
um they keep dropping the name of the
blackfish who's retaken Riverrun and
they've also just you know hidden years
alive you know hey kids remember me nope
no we don't know who are you no I am I
remember idea but it's you've been gone
a long time so I thought it'd be helpful
to have a little refresher in why these
guys are so important so I start with
the blackfish himself he's been seeded
the longest I think so he's Brynden
Tully he's Catelyn Stark's uncle the
younger brother of hosta Tully who's
captain's dad and he's a distinguished
night and he's been married to the job
he's quite been a successful military
tactician um but he's never married so
and even though his brother has set him
up with some fine ladies he loves the
fishes he's he's the black so hid the
reason he's called black fish is because
he's the black sheep of the family and
because the Tully's love fish he's the
black fish and it's stuck it's also the
name of a very harrowing documentary on
netflix about sea world but so he's
called he's got the blackfish uh and in
Game of Thrones as we seen him he's been
he know he counseled Rob back when rob
was leading his king of the north king
of the north stuff he's eventually you
know quite unsuccessful king of an old
stuff and he warns catlin just about how
slippery and how dangerous Walder Frey
is so basically he's the only Tully
who's been speaking since yeah that's
what makes him the black sheet yeah yeah
um he's also like the world's luckiest
man Vickers at the red wedding he drank
too much and needed to pee and managed
to escape at the exact moment that the
massacre started what a time to go for a
piss just perfect do you think that was
a coincidence a lit I don't know maybe
he's got like some fish sense that tells
him like he was just so scared like he
was wetting himself is not good
okay gotta go um I don't know in Game of
Thrones I don't believe in coincidence
anymore I like to think that he I don't
know would he know like even if you did
know we know what I mean if he's if he's
already warning people duh you know
Walder Frey is not a wholesome dude like
he might be getting a feeling like I
don't let this man I gotta go and I go
pee on a tree he heard the rains of
castamere Nia's like I'm out peace no
but rains he was like oh you be loopy
flushing meadows uh so where he's been
in the last couple seasons he's been
rebuilding the Tully army and as we know
from Littlefinger who's a trustworthy
source for a change uh he's taken river
run back the homeland of the Tully's
from the phrase which is awesome so we
also know the Brienne of Tarth is on her
way to go and treat with him and trying
to support for son Cesare me up in the
north but what I am thinking now is that
now we know that Jaime Lannister's on
his way is he gonna have men to spare
like I assume Jamie's gonna bring the
Lannister hordes they're gonna have
whatever support is left from the phrase
I don't know if he's managed to make
build that many men yeah I'm not too
sure Eva I mean no one likes the phrase
either even the Lannisters well as
they're meant to be allies and the whole
reason like phrase were like oh I'm
gonna kill your enemies in one fell
swoop Lannisters because he was meant to
marry my gross door and now he's not so
screw those guys but maybe like you
mentioned Brienne mmm we saw Brianna and
Jamie get quite close mmm don't you dare
take no no no no no they're just they're
just good friends they're just good
friends David they became quite quite
friend they had a mutual respect region
yeah so if she turns up at the same time
maybe her and Jamie can work something
out like we see we know the phrase have
got a demure and the whole point of that
him they're having him is to use him to
break the siege hmm so that there's a
lot of characters in play all with kind
of their own agendas it's basically
gonna whose agenda is going to come out
up yeah speaking read me on let's have a
little brief reminder of him so he is
catlins brother and he's been as we
found out kept in a dungeon for the last
three seasons so he is you remember he's
the kind of more hot-headed emotional
Tully I guess they all are to a degree
but when when their dad died when hasta
died he had to you know like the the
funeral pyre on fire with a bow and
arrow could do it just kept missing so
that's when Brendan actually got
involved was like give me that he's a
little bit ashamed of his nephew in his
hotheadedness um so he's technically
ahead of house Tully and when Robb Stark
all he needed to do was marry Walder
Frey's daughter to secure that treaty
but instead he pissed him off and
married what was a name to Lisa Connie
remember whenever I think about I just
have that flashing image of the red
wedding in in Game of Thrones they have
the weird bedding ritual which is like
everyone being like yeah you're gonna
have sex and like he you know picked her
and Roslin Frey and admire and took them
up to their bedroom and then they just
captured him so he's just been sad there
I always assumed they'd killed him yeah
yeah Sam um so Edna is now bargaining
chip unless you're busy yeah it doesn't
seem it doesn't yeah this doesn't bode
well for him I mean is anyone else gonna
really kill I do it before you're dead
already so um tell me camera i know i
guess like house Tully though they are
they have strong family ties but also I
think Littlefinger might care yeah
because if Littlefinger they all grew up
together so if little fingers aware
which I'm he probably is yes everything
I see him he's gonna at least maybe send
the night of the veil there maybe that's
why because Santa's already refused his
help so maybe he helps out there first
and then secures that Alliance and then
the orgo up so is this whence answer
refused the troops mmm is that white
thing little fingers sewed like oh by
the way blackfish user so she knew he
should go that he knew he should go
there and in the stalemate that's going
to come from like the the black Fisher's
troops and Jamie's troops and the fray
troops like little things just gonna
step in with his army of like super veil
night like listen out I'd like to see
that happen
you